how about after the show a little game
of 8-ball well I would chubby but I've
lost my eye it's really not worth as
nonsense what about him hey man I'm ball
come on well I mean if you really have
to I guess we could play a little bit
sure maybe we can make a little wager
how about your house lose my pants here
well there's something to be said for
comedy the nominees for Best Performance
by an actress in a leading role are
Meryl Streep in iron
Sally Kirkland and Anna
then close in fatal attraction
Holly Hunter and broadcast
[Applause]
winner is Sharon
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now I want to really I want to really
say something when I was little my
mother said I want you to be something
and and and I guess this represents 23
or 24 years of my work and I've never
won anything before from my peers I'm
really really happy
I'd like to thank everyone I worked on
with the movie they were really fabulous
it was really a great experience for me
my makeup man we had a lot to work with
my hairdresser my assistant my children
who've been so wonderful the lady who
taught me how to speak in this Brooklyn
accent and I would like to thank the
women that I was nominated along with
because I feel really really good
because they were so great and I also
would like to thank Mary Louise Streep
who I feel so unbelievable that I did my
first movie with her and now I was
nominated with her and I feel really
thankful
and I don't think that this means that I
am somebody but I guess I'm on my way
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]